all right we have a great question from
the audience uh let me read it now that
you've been doing the daily show for
almost a month how are you feeling are
you getting tired of it i've been loving
it just hoping you don't burn out well
thanks for thinking of me i am getting
tremendous energy from it uh nema it is
uh kind of put me into a rhythm where i
wake up i do a little email do a little
news get the girls ready for school
and have a cup of uh cold brew we make
the cold brew at home with the chicory
coffee
from cafe du monde kevin dumont chicory
coffee
great that's cold brew make it at home
don't buy the blue bottle stuff save a
ton of money and um
it's giving me energy it's making me
think and it's making me work on my
performance and i'm
starting to tackle bigger picture issues
so
i like this
uh rhythm i'm in and what i really love
the most i'll be totally honest is the
noti gang the notification gang where
people turn on notifications on youtube
at youtube.com this weekend
and then
when i come online to see the same
twenty thirty forty people say no to
gangnam nerdy gang nobody gang
dory gang means you have your
notifications turned on and we get to
bond right and i'm kind of building
those relationships with y'all and i
hope to meet you all in person at some
point and it's interactive and you ask
great questions you give feedback and i
think you'll start producing the show
and what i mean by that is we have three
full-time producers plus charles on the
ones and the twos doing the av and the
recording and everything
i would like to see you the audience
saying hey j cal you talked about
you know the amazon driver uh issue
uh you read the motherboard story but
you didn't see this
uh interview that the founder from that
netradine did um he actually addressed
this right here or did you know that
this person is suing in this court
because of elizabeth holmes and it's not
being reported so i really like to see
you the audience get more involved and
be
you know feeding
us some story ideas and guess you want
to have on and then i've also enjoyed
the live guests that's been really
interesting to me is to pull a reporter
in live so you know my schedule's a
little bit messy like sometimes i can do
9 a.m 10 a.m 11 a.m sometimes a founder
calls me in the morning throws
everything off so i've been a little
loosey-goosey about the time it's
basically before 11 o'clock i start
typically uh and we go for 20 minutes or
two hours and so it's kind of like
hosting a morning show without having an
official start time that's why
we have the naughty gang but i'm loving
it it's not burning me out if anything
it's giving me energy the thing i am
concerned about is five days a week it
could lead to burnout and what if i get
sick so you guys remember i was sick the
last two weeks had a low grade cold it
might have been
a standing ammonia
um and so
you know if i if i do get actually sick
that's gonna throw things off because we
used to do is just do 20 interviews at
any given point in time we'd have five
or ten in the bang
taping two or three that week five that
week we just you know we're doing
interviews but i like the show being
news then interview news then interview
because you get two swings at the bat
with the audience as well you can listen
to me in the news and you're like i
don't care about michael dell i mean you
should care about michael that's a great
interview or you could be like you know
jason i don't care about this google ad
stuff with zach i'm just gonna go right
to the michael dell story so i like
there being four or five things per
episode uh but it would help if i had a
co-host and that's why producer rachel
is starting to do some uh segments in
the field so you'll see her doing a
segment a week i think maybe two when we
get at scale here and then you never
know maybe a co-host will show up at
some point and help me do this uh so
that would be great if i had
eventually a co-host uh who could
be chiming in but you guys really seem
to like when the producers come in too
so
it's just uh it's super engaging for me
and i'm loving it so thanks for asking